Five. At no point has Bonell disputed that he threatened plaintiff
and her witnesses with physical harm in retaliation to their
allegations and testimony in this action. Who? Excuse me. What?
Who? What? What? W There are three witnesses to this case. When
who when have I publicly threatened physical harm to any people?
What? Yeah. I um for Anna that's just I if I could I do it. Um
but not for Anna. people dox her is what you're saying. Yeah.
No. What the like why would I even want to do that? Like what
am I want somebody to kill her? What like that's I do want somebody
to logistical though or laugh or in retaliation to their allegations
and testimony in this action. Who excuse me what who what
there are three witnesses to this case. When who when have I
publicly threatened physical harm to any of these people? What?
Yeah. I um for Anna that's for Jess and Queen I'd kill him if
I could. I choke the house and do it but not for Anna. No people
to dox her is what you're saying. Yeah. No. What the like why
would I even want to do that? Like what am I want to kill or
what? Like that's I do want somebody to logistical though or
laugh or or that he publicly harassed and ridiculed plaintiff's
legal team. Yes, I am publicly ridiculing you. Harassment? What
is it? Harassment to read your filings and make fun of them.
In light of the standard language of plaintiff's proposed protective
order, there can be no explanation for Bunnel's objections there,
too. Other than that, Bunnel intends to continue to threaten
and harass plaintiff, her fact witnesses in her legal team. Oh
my god, dude. Didn't you say some crap about Justicle? First
of all, that was in a private um interview to Willie Mack. Number
one, I didn't publish that. Number two, Justicle is not a witness
to this case. Number three, this is and plaintiff and her witnesses.
Did they ever formally do they even formally accuse you of that?
Well, they put they throw it in all their f like this is like
I don't even want to like participate in this. Like this just
feels stupid. Is this I'm probably gonna send a big email asking
about because like this is just they're posting like this is
so dumb. I've got to pay $20,000 to respond to this motion while
they make up with chat GPT and at me like a bunch of people that
shouldn't even be allowed to appear in a federal court like let
alone try a case like this. They clearly have no experience in
this in this realm like in anything. Like it's so this is so
unhinged.
Every single case I've looked up either doesn't support their
claim or cuts against them in the exact opposite in this one
motion. That doesn't include all the other random that I've looked
at for equally unpersuasive or bunnel's remaining case citations.
As none, he acts shocked who what what at the allegation from
doc 73 para 7 that he threatened plaintiff and her witnesses
with physical harm. He asks when have I publicly threatened physical
harm to any people. He then says the justical comment was in
a private interview and justicle is not a witness. Paragraph
7 of doc 73 states defendant has publicly threatened physical
harm to individuals that have spoken out against him and in support
of plaintiff then gives the
quote. It doesn't explicitly say he directly threatened Jane
Doe or the three anonymous declarance ab by name with physical
harm. It says his threats against others who support plaintiff
or speak against him create an environment of intimidation relevant
to protecting the current witnesses. The JSDLK/Quiman
quote, even if from a private interview with Willie Mack, was
clearly made public enough for plaintiffs team to obtain it and
present it to the court via email exhibit in doc 723. If the
interview was published or shared, it's effectively public. The
impact of the threat is what matters, not just the initial setting.
This is a deflection. The argument from plaintiff's team is that
his willingness to make such violent statements about anyone
critical of him or supportive of his opponents creates a chilling
effect and risk for their witnesses.
The threat doesn't have to be against a named witness in this
specific case for it to be relevant to a request for witness
protection from harassment and intimidation. Plaintiff's team
might be using threaten more broadly to include creating an atmosphere
of fear and intimidation, not just direct I will harm witness
X statements. The defendant denies directly threatening the plaintiff
or her specific current witnesses by name with physical harm.
The plaintiff's court filing document 73 actually alleges he
threatened other individuals who spoke out against him or supported
the plaintiff providing a specific quote. The plaintiff's argument
is that this general pattern of alleged violent rhetoric justifies
protecting her current witnesses from a similar climate of intimidation
even if those specific witnesses weren't named in that particular
quote. Show the quote from doc 73723.
Can I turn the contrast up somehow? It's just annoying seating
and ensure the process. protect the safety and privacy of parties.
What is he like when he talks about this on stream now, he's
like very very um adamant that he's in fear of his life. Like
he acts like he's legitimately worried that I'm signaling to
people to show up and and kill him. It's it's just hilariously
stupidly unhinged. But plaintiff's council in doc 73 par 7 and
the email from Joan Peters in doc 723 raised concerns about Bonnel's
publicly documented statements threatening others JSDLK qman
lav Mr. girl and argued this created a need to protect their
witnesses from harassment, retaliation, and harm. They weren't
necessarily saying council himself was in fear for his own life
from Bonel directly, but that Bonel's rhetoric creates a dangerous
environment for those opposing him. The quote Joan Peters attributed
to Bonel for JSDLK and Qmen. I'd kill them if I could. I do want
someone to JSDLK though is what plaintiff's team put before the
court in doc 723 exhibit B which is an email from Joan Peters
to Breler and referenced again in doc 73.
Bonel is downplaying the seriousness of his own alleged words
that were presented to the court as a reason for witness protection.
The defendant is mocking the plaintiff's lawyer's concerns about
safety. However, the plaintiff's team presented specific disturbing
quotes to the court as seen in document 723 and referenced in
document 73 attributed to the defendant about wanting named individuals
killed. It's this alleged rhetoric that forms the basis for their
concerns about witness safety and retaliation, not necessarily
a claim that council himself is about to be physically attacked
by the defendant. Isn't this going to leave her completely broke?
My guess is the um attorneys,
at least one of them I think is a family friend and I think that
they're just doing it pro bono. So she's probably just stealing
your money from the from the Gibson and go. He admits it's a
guess. This is not factual. Accusing someone of stealing is a
serious allegation. Giveso funds are typically used for legal
fees and case related expenses unless specified otherwise by
the campaign. Even if one lawyer is pro bono, there are other
lawyers, court costs, expert fees, etc. himself notes plaintiff
and her friend Miss Hayden also created a giveo page to raise
money to cover plaintiff's legal fees in her lawsuit against
me. He acknowledges the stated purpose. The defendant speculates
the plaintiff is stealing donations, but he offers no proof.
His own court declaration document 421 acknowledges the fundraiser
was for legal fees. Legal battles are expensive, involving multiple
lawyers and various costs beyond just one attorney's time. Is
it possible that she knows that she has lost, so she's literally
just trying to rack up your legal expenses? Yes, that is exactly
what is happening. And she admits, I would argue they admit to
as much in the transcript, but that's why they move to seal that
transcript because they know that that transcript, at least publicly
and legally, I would argue, crucifies the out of them, but that's
why they move to get that sealed so quickly.
He complains about the cost of responding to motions he claims
are made up with chat GPT by inexperienced lawyers. He states
every case they cite either doesn't support their claim or cuts
against them. This is his personal legal research and opinion.
His lawyers make legal arguments in court. The judge decides
if the case law cited by either side is persuasive and applicable.
He is not the arbiter of what constitutes good legal argument.
The defendant is expressing frustration with legal costs and
is making unsubstantiated claims about how the plaintiff's lawyers
prepare their court documents. He also offers his personal opinion
on their legal research. However, it's the judge who evaluates
the legal arguments and the applicability of cited cases presented
by the qualified attorneys on both sides. Both sides site case
law. Sometimes interpretations differ or one side might misapply
a case. This is normal in litigation. Hold on one second. Oh
no.
Sorry. Hold on. I'm not reading from anything. I just had a um
I just had a recollection of a back and forth in court, but I'm
not reading from anything. I was just looking at something totally
unrelated. Um but it was really funny because I remember I remember
at some point the judge had asked her. He was like, "So when
did you first find out about these Google Drive links?" because
they're trying to run with this the Google Drive argument that
they lifted from Kiwi Farms basically. And at one point I think
the judge is asking her about um uh when did you first learn
about like the the Google Drive stuff? And she's like, "Well,
uh I don't remember this at all, but I think that he sent me
stuff relating uh of him and his uh wife at the time or whatever."
And he was like, "Well, when did that happen?" And she was like,
"Um, I don't know, but it was before we ever met before." And
I think the um the judge said something like he's like wait so
you sent he sent you a video of of him and his ex-wife hooking
up and she was like I believe so. Yeah. And then he's like and
that didn't give you pause to think for a moment that you guys
were sh It was
oh it was some funny oh my god. And then she tried to roll with
the the the argument where I think she started to say well no
uh zip do you remember this? And then she starts being like,
"Well, I I heard that they were in an open relationship, so I
figured, you know, that, you know, maybe they just were more
free or they didn't give a about anything." Oh my god. Okay,
sorry. Were they successful in sealing the transcript? No, it's
just it's temporarily sealed by the judge rules on it. So cringe.
Oh my god, it was so cringe. The defendant is sharing his personal
memory of a court hearing. However, without a public transcript,
we can't verify this exchange. What matters legally is the evidence
and testimony officially on record. Even if Pixie did receive
a video of him and his ex-wife, which she might deny or contextualize
differently, it does not legally mean she consented to her own
intimate video with him being shared with Rose or others. This
is a classic improper character evidence or victim blaming tactic,
trying to suggest that because she might have been open about
in one context, she's open in all contexts. Even if we take the
defendant's recollection at face value, legal principles and
the plaintiff's own objections in court, like those in document
68, argue that a person's past history or openness, doesn't automatically
mean they consent to every future act or the sharing of every
intimate video. Consent is specific to each situation.
That was totally irrelevant. A lot of which they've admitted,
by the way, is utter. I don't know if that's private or if that
was part of the hearing, but in the hearing they admitted that
like half the people had deleted their accounts that they had
no one of the Oh, I don't know if I said this or not. One of
the very specific lines of questioning, by the way, was, "Have
you seen evidence relating to ABMC, the Mr. President? Have you
seen evidence that Steven Bunnell transmitted any video to her
at all, or is it just her saying it to a friend?" And after some
back and forth, um, she answered, "No, I've never seen any evidence."
And the question was, have you seen any evidence of him transmitting
this video to anybody at all beyond the Rose person? And the
answer was an unequivocal no. Meaning that the Abby person lied
as I said they did. They I knew cuz I know they did cuz I went
back and they purged themselves in their declaration. But not
only did she commit perjury, the law firm itself was at at at
best reckless because how are you having her fill out a declaration
when you can't even you should have seen the evidence, right?
If she's saying she has it, why wouldn't you check it first?
It's because they're It's because they're just trying to survive
summary judgement. That's the goal. I don't know even know why.
Like they want to go to trial, I guess. I have no idea. I don't
know what the goal is. But um defendants argue if some potential
witnesses deleted accounts that doesn't invalidate the testimony
of those who did provide declarations like Abim, witness A, witness
B. Document 83, Bonnell's opposition to compel Lulco. In footnote
one, Bonel's lawyer state in her declaration, Abim claims that
Bonel sent her the video on or about November 3, 2023. However,
Abim provided no support for this baseless contention and failed
to attach any exhibits reflecting the alleged transmission of
the video. The defendant claims the plaintiff admitted in a hearing
that she saw no evidence of him sending the video to ABMC.
His own lawyers in document 83 acknowledge ABMC's declaration
does claim he sent her the video. The defense argues ABMC didn't
attach proof to her declaration. This is different from the plaintiff
supposedly saying no evidence exists at all. The plaintiff might
not have personally seen the evidence ABMC has, but that doesn't
mean ABMC is lying. It's up to Abby MC to present her evidence.
Why is Discovery going to last until December? I think that it
just takes a while
for court cases. Destiny, that's a Kiwi Farms argument. Blab
argues you convince girls that recording is normal by sending
them stuff. Oh, sure. Yeah, they they borrow a lot of their arguments
from Kiwi Farms. Did I mention the paper shuffling yet? There's
a lot of times um there's a lot of times where the judge where
I'm sorry where um opposing council on cross Yeah. is like asking
me like some line of questioning and it's just so stupid and
at some point he just picks up his papers and starts cuz I can
tell that he's like himself on on whatever line of questions
that he had for me because it's just so stupid. This is an attempt
to discredit the plaintiff's arguments by associating them with
a controversial source rather than addressing the merits of the
arguments themselves. He offers no specific examples or proof
of this claim. The defendant claims the plaintiff's legal arguments
are borrowed from a controversial website. This appears to be
an attempt to discredit the arguments by association rather than
addressing their legal substance. Lawyers base their arguments
on law and facts relevant to the case.